hi everyone
uh and uh thanks to the organizers for
uh
for really an excellent workshop and
i'll just give a shout out to uh to
peter bartlett as well
because uh you know he's successfully
taken over the mantle from alistar
and just the work he's been doing is a
tremendous service
to the community so it's uh yeah it's
awesome to see that
uh although all the programs still going
on
so uh as we're all uh experts
in uh in reinforcement learning
i'm going to you know assume standard
background knowledge
and standard notation and the talk is
largely going to focus on
both some basic issues but given our
audience also touch upon
some subtle points as to what we might
be missing and things that
could potentially help us move forward
so
we're going to be looking at the space
of policy optimization which
uh we know is effective in many uh
different tasks and
some of the questions you want to get at
is uh both what's going on
and how to improve them so these are
issues with regards to like look
these methods are great for dealing with
large state and action spaces because of
how you can plug
these newer network into them but we'd
like to understand uh what's the right
way to think about
the these neural networks uh with
regards to their approximation power in
these methods
uh the you know these methods are very
easy to compute gradients but we like to
get a handle on
convergence and finally we also want to
think about how
they the interplay between these methods
and exploration
okay and just around the same page uh
let's
uh go through this example from actually
from sebastian throne's thesis
i believe uh this is a little toy
example where you have like you know
agent starts at s0 the rewards all the
way at the right
uh uh at estates away
and uh if you act randomly starting at a
zero
uh you know it's a random walk with a
drift with two thirds chance going
backward one third chance
uh moving to the right so if you act
randomly starting it
uh you aren't gonna get to the reward
with you know it's
exponentially slow probability and what
that translates to in terms of an
optimization problem is
you know your gradients are flat and not
like the type of nice supervised
learning flat gradients where you shake
the system a little and you escape from
yasada point these gradients are flat
to very high orders so so the the
gradients are
are flat to order uh like s over two
like the length of the chain almost
uh so uh so you shouldn't expect like
a gradient descent method to solve this
problem
if you just started as zero and uh and
you know even just shake the system a
little
uh and you know how do we fix this well
ultimately
we'd like to solve the exploration
problem for this talk we're largely
going to cheat
with a with a practical cheat which is
we often assume some measure over the
state space that has coverage
and we'd like to understand what's going
on uh in terms of this
uh in terms of this coverage parameter
and
this is an idea that uh you know it's
it's uh people have thought about this
a fair bit with regards to how we can
use this measure
to make the problem easier by relating
uh
some notion of our supervised learning
era to uh
to policy improvement okay so you know
things we're going to think about is
what's this role of mu with policy
optimization
uh you know how to think about new
networks and are we visiting some
questions uh i'll we'll think about like
what we might be missing and i'm just
gonna pepper in like a few conjectures
here and there
uh as well okay so
uh basically we're gonna look at
uh both uh you know optimization
uh ideas and generalization ideas uh
we'll start with
uh the the tabular case where we're just
gonna
literally look at uh the the problem
where the number of states
the number of states and actions are
small uh but even here it actually helps
to start okay there's a typo there i'm
gonna start with like the vanilla policy
gradients and look at regularization
and the natural gradients uh but even
there we'll start understanding what
might be going wrong with regards to
exploration and how to think about the
landscape then we'll jump into
a linear policy as a warm-up but then
really trying to get into newer policies
and try to get at understanding what the
approximation power of
uh these methods are and uh and
you know mention a few comments after
and if you uh those of you around for
like the little break
i think mark and i had a little
impromptu discussion and one of the
the questions he was asking is how do we
think about what the projection step
looks like when we're using uh various
neural notions approximation and i'll
actually be getting into what that means
with regards to
policy gradient methods okay so jump in
uh jumping in with the small state space
case we're really going to focus on the
softmax policy class because
it's really just you know one of the
most basic ways to parameterize the
space of all stationary policies
you're basically going to get policies
that look like this if you just take a
vanilla gradient step
uh and do some kind of proximal
projection back onto the simplex
uh with the kl you're going to also get
kind of policies that
look like this again and the question
here is
you know do we have a global convergence
the problem
you know you can easily come up with
examples showing it's non-convex
and what are the things that govern the
convergence rates
okay so the first claim is if you just
do straight up
vanilla gradient ascent over this policy
class
and you have the condition that this
measure so now we're not going to
optimize just from s0 we're going to
have a starting state distribution that
has
uh support everywhere then you will
asymptotically get convergence okay
uh and you know it isn't convex but in
the limit you'll get
uh convergence okay so a couple uh
you know uh uh conjectures here so
the proof here is uh it's definitely
like it's super technical and it's just
asymptotic it's basically like
a lot of analysis uh and recently uh
may uh and chava here and a few others
show that the asymptotic convergence
rate uh here is one over t
after uh t iterations and
uh just a couple of conjectures uh again
like
don't uh very you know very varying
strength of my belief in these
conjectures but uh this
uh assumption that this measure is full
support i think it's pretty important
that if you don't have it at least for a
fixed learning rate i
actually believe you will not converge
even though your
policy is stochastic so there is a
chance you're going to wander around
everywhere
i actually do not think you will
converge uh
with this class even asymptotically
it's a conjecture i also think that the
uh the rate the finite time rate in this
method
could be arbitrarily uh bad in terms of
either the state space of the horizon
and what's going on is that even though
you if you have nice coverage over your
state space it seems like you're solving
the
uh the exploration problem but you're
getting killed due to your action
exploration because
of the soft max kind of collapsing your
actions did become
deterministic emma mentioned this point
as well that like there's reason to
believe in other settings we're kind of
watching the
uh the action exploration and i think
this is actually pretty
uh generic in in other settings i'll
come back to this point later
but uh you know this thing we're
definitely watching the action
exploration
uh so one thing to try is
uh in addition to giving us
a kind of coverage with a start state
measure let's also add in a regularizer
to try to keep the actions as being uh
for being diverse
so here we're going to use the kl
distance to the uniform distribution
this is a bit different from the
entropy regularization and what's
interesting here
is uh you can actually get a fully
polynomial rate of convergence in terms
of the number of states s the number of
actions the target accuracy
and the horizon uh provided again mu
has like say uniform and if it's not
uniform you can write it in terms of the
usual
uh kind of density or issues and the
proof here is actually
pretty concise and revealing unlike this
like
asymptotic proof
so again another point here is i'll come
back to this later
uh with some comments but in practice
people often use entropy rather than kl
and entropy is
actually um uh it really if you look at
the shape of the entropy function
it's just not such a strong penalty to
force
uh action expiration and again charba in
that same paper
they show if you use entropy instead you
will get uh
asymptotic uh convergence at a rate of
one over t
or better depending on how if you keep
lambda fixed or
decaying it uh now i do have a
conjecture that
with regards to the dependence on the
states and actions
uh so with regards to the size of the
state space or the horizon
even if your starting distribution was
like uniform
so you don't have this exploration
problem entropy
regularization uh i'm not convinced it's
strong enough to give you
uh a rate that's sort of poly in the
number of states like i think there's
some pretty bad collapsing i'll come
back to this with
things we're missing uh and i'm not like
necessarily advocating for kl
either but at least we should get things
right we should understand what's
happening in the tabular case
because i think this is important
because we aren't even getting things
right there
um you know we're watching something
more gen
more generally so i'll come back to uh
some of the insights here that uh you
know at least you can get iterate i'm
not necessarily pushing
that this is the uh the greatest way to
regularize
uh either to enforce this okay but
again there's another conjecture that i
don't think entropy is going to cut it
for getting
a poly uh s coefficients
okay so now let's go to a tabular method
uh 3 which is uh you know the problem is
coming in is
we're trying to move around on this a
constrained simplex and
uh you know what we often do is try to
work the distance metric to stretch the
corners out so we move more and
you know there's a bunch of variants of
this now but there's
uh you know this is what this natural
gradient is doing and there's a bunch of
other
variants where you can look at this as a
certain type of proximal
update as well but you're just um you
know moving the the gradient direction
with a preconditioner given by this
fischer metric
under a particular weighting which
stretches the corners out
uh for the tabular case actually for
even more general cases
this actually has this nice
softmax policy iteration update form
and you know to some extent this is why
we refer to these analysis methods
npg because of this connection
uh for a while back of understanding how
you can view this as a soft policy
iteration update role so for the tabular
case
uh this is a completely equivalent
update rule if you look at how your
policy changes
so uh so again let's look at our tabular
uh
convergence rate and uh
and then wrap up our tabular story uh so
what's interesting here
is that uh again all of the tabular
stuff was we're assuming exact gradients
and we're working this like oracle model
if someone gives us exact
gradients and we're looking at iteration
complexity to
getting like an epsilon optimal solution
and again this is a non-convex update
rule
what's pretty neat here is that there's
a relatively clean analysis
that shows that uh you know the rate is
one over t
with uh where the iteration complexity
has no dependence on
the number of states or actions uh and
it's a fast rate which you know from the
optimization side
that's that's pretty neat uh the
analysis
as like nevin i mentioned it actually
really just goes back to
this um to particular
online analysis of uh thinking about
expert algorithms but
uh somehow even though it's non-convex
the
it's a pretty clean analysis to see
that this update rule actually quite
quickly converges to the right answer
with iteration complexities that don't
depend on
uh the number of states or actions
interesting here you don't even need
like
uh full support uh for the
uh you know for the states or the action
distributions
uh but again this is all coming down to
the fact that we're assuming
exact gradients but even that is
interesting because these other methods
uh you actually do need stronger
conditions to get
them to converge at at all let alone
getting
getting the rates to be uh correct so
now we're
we get a sense of uh what's governing
our
uh convergence rates and how you know
certain issues are coming up
and we really want to see the interplay
between that
and what happens when we use approximate
gradients
and sample gradients to deal with large
uh state spaces because now we're going
to have function classes
and you know what's going on and you
know in this in your case like what's
the right way to think about
the um the
the kind of quote-unquote projection
step that's going to go on
if we use a neural policy class
so let's keep on with our
uh you know variance of soft max
parameterizations so we're going to
generalize it to say the chance of
taking action in
s is now uh you know the log of that
is proportional to
some energy function where f is like uh
telling us
the energy of taking action a this
clearly contains the the softmax class
if we just use
this uh you know this tabular
parameterization
the log linear policy class this is a
nice warm-up
case uh before we go to a richer policy
classes where
we say this energy function is linear
in some known features and then uh
finally we'll look at uh what happens
when f theta is a is a neural network
and you know one of the i'll come back
to this again in just some comments
one of the ways that gradients are nice
compared to like various other
uh kind of incremental methods is what i
call them
uh is it keeps a compact policy class
like at the end of the day
you're gonna spit out one neo network
which is uh
what your policy is doing and you know
going back to some of these older papers
like
cpi psdp i think bruno
basically is pointing out that like cpi
is like boosting and like look boosting
in uh
in like vanilla supervised learning it's
a complete headache because you get this
god awful mess
of mixtures of classifiers and we know
like this thing works great
but just holding this sucker in memory
is awful
and i think a similar thing is going on
here like neo networks give us a very
compact way
to keep around one policy and how should
we think about that
in light of uh say these um
these prior works about uh incremental
methods where we don't have compact
policy classes
okay so starting up with a warm up which
is the linear policy uh class
uh so what the npg update or variant of
this will look like which i'll give a
theorem for
is rather than uh you know
doing an update which is e to the exact
queue you'll have this projection step
where you project the q values uh onto
your
function space phi and
there's a sort of choice of the measure
we want to do here one subtle point is
i'm going to use a measure which has
support over the actions as well i'll
come back to that
uh okay so so so uh two points here i'm
doing a projection step with the queues
on defy
and the distribution is almost on policy
but i'm gonna start it with a measure
that
has support not only over states but
over all the actions and that
bit over actions is going to be
important here
okay so that's how we uh define the
the sort of fit w star so ws is really a
function of the current theta
and then the update rule if it was exact
would be again the soft policy update
rule
and and this is basically equivalent to
the npg i'll come back to that in a
moment
and and you know we're going to give a
theorem for the sample sample-based
variant of this
which is you know rather than using the
exact fit you use an
uh on policy fit and you know this is a
warm-up case because
uh um you know linear in practice we
often use richer policy classes this
variant is it's basically
like politics for the analysis we're
going to do there's a minor difference
with emphasizing
just a quick dumb question um where does
s0 and a0 appear in your expression for
w star
ah great yes uh uh so this is on behalf
of man we were just starting to discuss
on the
yeah yeah so uh so this on policy is
really
uh it's it's uh it's this expression so
so the way you're gonna get samples is
you sample s0 or a0 from you
then you execute your policy pi you cut
off at a random time and take the s and
a you get to
okay so you could cut off at zero as
well but
uh your state action measure is on
policy
starting from s zero or a zero okay and
that gives you a little bit of action
exploration
and that's kind of uh important to
stress here okay
so so again similar ideas are in uh
politics i think
i'm emphasizing this and again this is a
warm up but uh the emphasis on this
starting
action distribution is actually pretty
uh important here
okay so i'm gonna happen for a second to
say uh you've got about four
[Music]
minutes left okay sounds good uh so
uh to so the
assumptions we'll make for now let's
just do realizability so assume q is
contained in the projection i'll come
back to how you can
relax that uh we're still going to have
error
which is like just a supervised learning
era so this is there should be a
subscript there but this is on policy
supervised learning error
fix that in the later version and the
nice thing about the uh
uh having this uh measurement is now you
this condition number here you can write
completely
path free so this is a ratio between uh
the the covariance matrix of any
comparator
policy or the optimal policy and your
starting measure
okay and this is why you really need
this action exploration
to make sure you get future coverage
because without that this thing could be
arbitrarily bad
okay and if you have this again it's
realizability i'm assuming but i'm still
assuming error
in uh on policy something here
then you'll get uh you know convergence
at a rate
now one over root t it depends on your
horizon
and you get
something that depends on your
statistical error your statistical risk
and an ampli amplification factor due to
this
a relative condition number how well
your features
cover up but the interesting thing about
this relative condition number
it has nothing to do with the path of
your algorithm
because of this choice of mu okay
and you know one point to make here is
uh this style uh is actually kind of
important because
we like in special cases uh our bonds to
hold like for linear mdps
uh because in cases like that you really
do have realizability
and some of these prior bonds just the
way we stated it
would not actually hold for these
special cases
so given the time constraints the change
we're going to have when we go to neural
policies
is you know now the question is what's
like the way to think about the
projection step when you have a neural
policy
okay so what's going to happen is so f
data is now in your network
it's basically the same style of the
guarantee we had before
except the future function now is going
to be a function of the current neural
network we have
so the future function is actually
the gradient of our neural network at
theta
minus its expected value okay and
uh if you forget about this last term uh
if f of theta was theta dot
phi the gradient of that is just phi
right so this
is basically the same as what we had
before so somehow what's
governing the way in which our newer
classes
are approximating things have to do with
kind of the gradient of this function
and that's what we really need to have
approximating the
the target value function and you might
expect this to happen for like
uh rich in your networks uh but again
that's just the fitting power of neural
networks
uh but this is a precise way to think
about uh
what the projection step that's going on
is
so what yeah so this is an exactly
equivalent way to do the npg update
which is
uh you literally do a projection of your
advantage
onto these neural features
which the neural features are induced by
a gradient okay and then you do
you can do the sample based version the
same mu
dependence and this would be
the one way to do a soft policy
iteration update
but i want to point out this is exactly
equivalent to this update rule
so suppose you were just doing uh the
natural gradient update rule which is
fischer inverse grad
the gradient where you literally plugged
in
this policy class that is equivalent to
this update rule
okay so this really is uh sort of this
offline discussion we have of what
this projection means for a neural
policy class
uh when we're doing policy gradients and
it actually has
an interesting connection to the value
function based methods
where the projection step is fitting
your advantages
under these particular features
now you're going to get a similar
guarantee
with uh with the neural policy crossing
there's some typos there but given time
constraints
uh you you can look at the paper the one
point i want to mention is
the reason the important distinction
here for the neural policy class
and why this is working is you need
your policy class to be smooth because
if your policy changes very
if your new network changes very very
quickly as your changes your parameters
then it's going to be very unstable so
it governs things like in addition to
the linear class we need an additional
assumption which is
something about a policy class being
smoothness a smoothness assumption
okay and let me just come back to that
point
for uh takeaways and wrap up okay so
uh i'll just go with it like like in
practice we're completely botching the
action action exploration i think ammo
is more applied about this but
i think in real settings uh we you know
look at montezuma's revenge
and things like that we're actually
collapsing our action exploration
uh quite badly and my take for
theory to practice is uh entropy
you know looking at the theory i do not
think it's aggressive enough and and
this is clear from experiments and i
am not pushing kale for theory kale is
great but i think kale
is a little too uh aggressive i think
something more reasonable is to
explicitly
not just think about coverage with your
starting measure just over states
but you want your starting measure to
have coverage over actions as well
that gets into variance issues but again
like
it on some cases i think this definitely
is more sane to do
than trying to do this with
regularization
okay so see the paper for relaxing uh
the realizability assumption i think one
point i want to make here is
the way we should relax this
realizability should still
allow us to capture cases like linear
mdps
and that really means a more refined way
to avoid these
uh kind of density ratio coefficients
and like somehow the only way to do that
is to break up approximation and
estimation because
if your class is realizable you you
really need a way to tease these
these two aspects apart because if you
don't do that the analysis
does not capture basic things like
linear mdps
okay and the last point i want to make
is uh you know what's going on with
regards to like these prior works or
like various incremental methods
it's basically if your policy class is
smooth
like your network is smooth then you
don't have to do
these boosting styles of tricks where
you have this huge ensemble of previous
policies
by just making small gradient changes
you will actually
stay in the policy class you have
at hand and have guarantees that look
basically like
all the guarantees we've been proving
for a while with regards to
various consensuality coefficients but
the main point is as long as our policy
class is smooth
uh we're getting compactness by staying
in this class
and with a similar style of guarantees
and we know
now the right way to think about the
approximation condition which is really
just due to this paper by
richard sutton david mcallister and co
on compatible
function approximation so um
you know again thanks a bunch so this
talk was really looking kind of at a
kind of an optimization and
generalization lens of what's going on
with a certain style of policy
optimization but i do think it's
revealing because
you know a lot of these ideas were
around before but i think just looking
at the tabular cases
uh you know a lot of work and some
subsequent work uh that we're getting a
sense of what are the issues at play
we see how those issues at play affect
the
um the function approximation setting
and you know there's many
open questions here from like you know
nuts and bolts issues to
uh you know much more general questions
about how we do exploration
uh and handle model in this
specification so uh
thank you very much fantastic thank you
sean this is a fantastic talk
um we are officially out of time but
since there are no more talks today i
think we can
um take some more time for questions so
uh i do want to be mindful of people who
might have to go but otherwise i'm sure
there's plenty of questions there's
plenty of
side channel chats so uh take it away
someone none you want to start
yeah so i want to comment or have a
question on the linear mvp comments
sean left at the end i think what sean
correct me if i'm wrong i think your
point is this right so when you measure
distribution shift here you're measuring
in a way that is
takes into the consideration of the
function class right so we're always
measuring like this like
uh eigenvalues of covalence matrix of
that which is a very tight way of
measuring
and i think the alternative that you're
mentioning the concentrability
is like just talking about like density
ratios right
uh but except and
desert ratios are indeed like you know
like stronger assumptions about theta
but if you're talking about linear mdps
density ratios work as well right
because in linear mdps all these
distributions
are complex combinations of the like the
right
factorization matrix uh so
uh density ratios uh
so it's a paying alec offline too but
the the issue
is so these sort of bonds they'll imply
the
previous consensuality bonds not the
realizable ones
but the the problem is uh you could have
atrocious uh density ratios and the
condition numbers
can be like d like the dimension and
this is real
and i this isn't like necessarily a
problem with the algorithms
the incremental ones it's an issue with
the uh
the analysis you see the point now is
what i'm trying to get at in
uh this sort of reinterpretation in the
paper is
there is the error due to the
statistical error
that's sort of how much you're off and
that
really is a conditioning effect which is
your features need coverage
and then there's a transfer learning
error and transfer learning error
uh can be arbitrarily bad and we know we
can pay density ratios and we just don't
have
a way to think about uh you know
when when extrapolation occurs so you
know like can you is talking about that
a bunch of people are talking about
distribution shift so
uh so so somehow the only way we can
separate these two effects
is to break this apart into two terms
which is the contribution from
the statistical error and that
contribution from the statistical error
we really do not pay a density ratio
term it's like
it's just strictly a better term the
density ratio
is really coming from uh the transfer
learning
distribution shift and you know in
practice transfer learning
is much better uh than we think it is
but the transfer learning
factor for the incremental method is
it's only transfer learning
to the optimal learning uh the optimal
policies measure
so that's why you know it's sort of too
subtle to get into
to this talk but it's very what's very
nice about not just
pg i think cpi psdp the boost
any of these incremental methods is uh
politics is the notion of transfer
is just to one distribution not to all
of them
so yeah right i see i see yes
i think it's a subtle point but uh yeah
i just had this you know
no no sort of the other thing i wanted
to just add there is right so
density ratio if you think about it is
trying to do a point wise correction of
expectation
right whereas really when you do
the the covariance thing you're you're
saying well first i'm going to take the
expectation and then i'm going to fix
the expectation which is
yeah either way right no no i i i think
there are two
separate issues here so first of all i
think i misunderstood
uh sean's point i think trump's point is
uh whether denominated or no whether the
numerator is d
pi star versus like max overall d pi
so yeah both both are yeah that's that's
right sorry yes
that's one thing but the the other so i
was ignoring that aspect but i think you
were talking about more of that and
there's a condition
as well i i was i was more talking about
the
like expectation of feeding transpose
versus directly comparing densities
yeah i think these two things in linear
and dps
are not that different no they're very
very different
they're very different way why we can we
can we can discuss again
they're really different because the the
other condition truly is a density ratio
and this uh you can always make a factor
of d
so uh so let's come back to that but i
think you know uh
the talk is too short to get into those
issues but i think to make progress this
isn't necessarily just something about
pg
it's just you know we just have to bite
the bullet and write out two terms in
the way we're
doing analysis and people are starting
to do that more now
i'm sure there's other comments brick
bats
questions
i see trevor you had many comments you
made during the presentation did you
want to jump in and talk about these
conjectures
oh it was just that one of the
contractors conjecture
number two has been resolved and the
answer is
like you're right and the situation is
even worse
[Music]
like depending on the initial condition
you can push these goals conservatory
high
and you can figure this to show that
yeah
now the thing is in practice this is why
i kind of made this action exploration
that like
well kl you can get the constants you
would never want to like kl
uh see what's going on because entropy
like even if
you're peaked entropy is always bounded
by like you know
k log k where k is your vocabulary size
right like
uh like the worst case for entry the
largest it can be
and it's and it's bonded below by zero
like it never explodes whereas kl
against uniform
if you go into the boundaries uh you
know you're saying zero when you should
be saying constant and it explodes
so kl will really keep you away from
those corners
uh so for theory this is great and you
can see that in the proof it's like a
couple steps
but in practice like i would not like i
think we might have tried it on
monozyma's revenge but like no no it is
too
uh aggressive so uh like entropy like
really does
keep you exploring uh a bit like in
montezuma's adventures like 17 actions
ngb keeps you like
jumping on two of them but you're
actually dropping
actions that you really should be taking
to uh to explore
so uh this issue of something more
explicit on your action exploration
uh like it really is needed uh and you
know it's not too surprising because
like you
can come from anyway it states you
should do it over states and actions
this is actually a good segue to maybe a
follow-up you
actually mentioned a little bit at the
end about
the importance of exploration and i'm
just wondering about whether this
optimization point of view is
is like we like this because it breaks
the problem into two problems but
is is this is a good thing or is this
not a good thing i i often wonder about
this
so um right so this is uh maybe i give
my uh
take this is kind of related to greg's
point like we should be calling this pg
like look at the end of the day i think
a family of incremental methods
are going to have similar styles of
guarantees and i think bruno has papers
kind of uh comparing them but i would
say
[Music]
maybe the issue isn't breaking them into
two parts a more technical way
i view this issue is uh because the end
of the day suppose we're doing something
like pcbg
or you know something more data
efficient which is
uh some more explicit exploration
the way i view this is how do we reuse
data effectively
and uh be robust to
a model miss specification and
pg the way these guarantees works is
they
they're polynomially efficient sample
wise but they're really not efficient
sample wise
in in practice but the reason they're
robust
is if you're not doing backups based on
previous data
you know like you're trying to be as
close to on policy as possible
in pg okay and that's great for
approximation guarantees
but you know for data reuse uh this is
like the example you have like data
reuse you want to do backups but if your
backups are wrong
it kills you and uh even when you're
incremental
like it just doesn't play well so the
way i would
say this it just really starts coming
down to how good
are our representations to leverage the
ability to
to reuse data and the more we can do
that
i think that you know both the more
aggressive we can be
uh and uh um you know the more
effective we can be with our you know
exploration so
that's sort of my you know last bullet
point on that
comment slide isn't that a nice research
problem by the way of kind of figuring
out
how much data you use you can tolerate
like not trying not to decide upfront
about like whether we're gonna
try to stay on policy or we're gonna use
all the data it's like
uh maybe we should be adaptive in some
way i really don't know
yeah yeah so i think uh this is good
i'll give a just a shameless plug to a
paper
uh so i need to read your uh linear q
star paper jar but like
uh you know i if it's true i owe you a
beer
i've been thinking about that problem
forever uh
so uh i owe you a beer if i if i believe
it so on your data
our reuse point uh and batch rl
this is a result along that flare that
uh if you assume realizability it's if
you're linear function class
and you have coverage over all the
features so
and you just want to do policy
evaluation so the best you could hope
for is
coverage this isn't enough to do batch
rl you get an xd
lower bound okay and again this is
pointing to
like what we're seeing in nrl is we kind
of need stronger
conditions to do the things we want to
do
so at least one of your uh
nan has like many upper bounds on what
the stronger conditions
are and uh and you know they're kind of
getting
uh close to each other but uh yeah so so
this is kind of uh
you know i agree with your point chava
and nan's been this is all nad has been
doing
yeah i just want to like this is
precisely the point i want to get at i
just chatted with that a little bit
so it seems like in the batch setting i
think this covariance matrix
uh coverage condition is very appealing
except that you guys showed all the
lower bound that says that in the
backside and this is just not that
useful right
and we need stronger conditions and i
think this is the paper that
my recent paper is like if you have
pretty strong density ratio type of
conditions
i can actually just get a realizability
to work uh
i i think it's pretty yeah you get these
like weird trade-offs like
you can you can have weaker data
assumptions but very very strong
function approximation assumption or
very strong data assumption but now we
know how to get rid of
all everything else other than
realizability yeah but it's
it's interesting to see how we're going
to proceed from here
yeah i mean the other thing i did want
to add there is so sort of the main
opportunity we have in this setting
is of course that because we are running
on policy algorithm
we can still be uh more adaptive about
how much history we're going to reuse so
that we don't sort of
uh we're into the land of being too much
off policy and
at least like in theory so uh so andrea
was doing some work with me this summer
on
on these sorts of questions and he is
finding that you can reuse
uh data from a lot of past it rates with
pretty much
even like important sampling type
corrections without
blowing up the variance of estimates and
that does provide actually a
reasonable reduction in sample
complexity um
so i i think sort of my my main
uh worry with a lot of data use type
questions especially
uh when thinking about the interaction
between sort of data reuse
and uh modeling assumptions has been
that okay you know
maybe maybe if i really assumed
something like a linear mdp
then i would feel very comfortable using
bellman backups and whatnot because
everything is sort of nice and linear
and
all backups are going to be close and
stable but if i want to be
robust to miss specification i don't
want to use them and you know
that really but this is the point that
for
our example uh if you just want to do
policy evaluation
uh you actually have your policies
linear in these features
and you have coverage over all the
features so here your backups are
actually truly unbiased and unbiased
every gives you unbiased all the way
through so these lower bonds actually
show
exponential variance in your uh your
estimate really
is this keep it on archive no it'll be
like uh almost done
uh almost done uh but but it's not a
crazy construction in like
two to the eighth it's like a very
you guys seen mangy uh i had had a paper
uh just very recently uh i think i see
my this year
but she was looking into this and then
she had matching or upper bounds
no but but uh travis she has uh inherent
belmonero assumptions
yeah that's the point right okay you
need a closeness
under belmont update i see i see
so right so somehow like this is kind of
the spectrum of like what are we leaning
on yeah
uh whether it comes to just evaluation
improvement
and like exploration and that's uh
you know why i don't have super high
hopes for like
unification because i think like how we
handle these things
you know my it's more a philosophical
point but i think in some settings
like our models are right like physics
and when your models are right like
physics
like you can predict back black holes
and they exist and then other settings
like biology and chemistry
you know your models are kind of poor
and you can lean on them a bit
but uh it's a very different style of
ways we think about our world and i i
think it's exactly the same issue
here that you know the domains are
really going to govern how much we can
lean on these different techniques
so i think partly you know there's
progress in understanding when they work
and i think alex point again in our
pre-chat
that helps us in you know how aggressive
we want to be like the type of things
that emma does
like in you know uh educational things
and like real science applications
you want to take a lot of care before
you deploy things and using off policy
stuff whereas if i'm doing
you know physics sort of stuff like
whatever it's all a compute i can try
things quickly as long as i don't break
my robot
so um that i mean that's more of my own
um personal take on on that issue
on this note uh feel free to continue i
am going to step out
and and join the canada town but this is
a fantastic discussion so
please feel free to stick around thank
you sean again for the talk
uh yeah thanks everyone uh thank you for
organizing
uh
all right i might uh